regardez juju a dit c'est comment ils
sont et l'émission cyril hanouna va
animer à partir du 18 mai une émission
que les téléspectateurs connaissent déjà
qu'ils s'appellent à prendre ou à
laisser sauf que ce sera sur ces 8es et
je crois que vous avez animé vous même
cette émission julien je l' ai animé sur
ces huit d'ailleurs c'était une superbe
série honnêtement c'est peut-être le jeu
qu'est le plus de suspense dans le monde
entier et ça va cartonner parce que la
mécanique est implacable et en tout cas
c'est cyril hanouna qui animera à partir
du lundi 18 mai à prendre ou à laisser
de retour sur ces oui alors je vous dis
remercié alors ok pour la promo mais
aussi il faut savoir que les enfants de
la télé est à prendre ou à laisser
ce sont les mêmes producteurs voilà
c'est le même groupe de production dont
je fais voilà donc voilà on fait tous
partie voilà tout ça donc c'est vrai
donc voila et merci alors ok mais c'est
vrai que merci à cette production
voilà de nous avoir fait un petit peu de
promo sur france 2 et pour lancer le jeu
et julien toujours aussi jean ces
classes est toujours aussi classe julien
alors justement julien courbet animés
jeux en 2014 et 2015 et arthur il anime
et jo de 2004 à 2006 et de 2010 à 2009 à
est ce qu'on voulait qu'on voit le style
julien courbet de cils arthur doit
démarrer passe-t-il julien courbet
regarde profité de chacune des secondes
qui vous sont offertes maintenant si
j'ai une chaîne iv avec vous ça va moi
aussi moi j'aime bien vraiment bien
il faut jouer aller on y joue encore de
boîtes à là je deviens pas là ça va être
compliqué quand même j'avais fait père
noël on a pris des essais telle quelle
occasion sa bas de noël
ça s'appelle
un double qu'à ses débuts j'ai cru que
ça serait construit ghabrit soirée bien
légiférer parce que alors bon courage et
surtout julien ne sait pas ce qui
l'attend les boîtes julien ils vont vous
avez passé une bonne soirée quand on
s'appelle haget vivre lui avait demandé
eh bien écoutez je vais demander parce
que c'est ma fille à bordeaux et ouais
alors ça c'est le style la courbe et
voilà que j'aime ou juju d'amour voilà
qui est bien et on va voir le style
arthurs et nous dire si vous n'êtes plus
le style julien courbet ou le style
arthur sur les boîtes et voilà moi je
vais démarrer lundi en direct
c'est la première fois que je vais en
direct et je fais un jeu comme un faut
regarder ça c'était le signal qu arthur
c'était dans une autre décennie ce temps
2015 regardez vous avez fait des
cochonneries hier soir ah oui plein
qu'est ce que vous avez fait un oui on
sait bien plus j'ai juste rêver vous
avez fait quoi comment et j'ai rêvé de
vos tenues way we à l'eau
oh
vous avez rêvé de moi de tout nu et
alors alors ça s'est très bien passé
tournez vous faites devant à oui c'est
comme un pull mais qui m'a mis elle
serait morte avant afin de le tricoter
faubel a déjà fait les manches a précédé
votre grand-mère qui nous regardent
pardonnez moi je plaisante
comme dans les chansons les draps s'en
souviennent alors que oui tu es bien
mouillé alors est ce que vous êtes plus
docile arthur ou le stylo julien
convoyer dit cela parce que franchement
les deux sont super bons oui mais moi
j'aime les deux c'est vrai je suis la
courbe et je trouve c'est avec vous mais
les 2 répartie un sens de la du timing
de la dance etc
je mettrai très bon vous serez excellent
aussi parce que vous en a qui avait
leaké mais si vous avez cse vie sont
donc ça c'est très bien pour le jeu et
mais lui il a beaucoup d'humour beaucoup
de répartie et vous arthur était bon
aussi dans les bois qu'il était mais
j'ai lavé et comptait plus sur les
candidats à laquelle je viens c'est plus
lui qui qui paie qui a fait du one man
ray série arthur aussi madr a fait du
one man est donc fait du one man en tout
cas pour animer chez eux c'est vrai
benjamin tal spécialiste du jour alors
avant la piscine j'allais dire
chirurgien courbet après la piscine je
vais choisir à l'élan françois nos
maisons mais dit la vérité
ah non moi je préfère le style de
courbet c'est vrai mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya il et voilà je trouve que dans le
dans le jeu même si elle souhaitait très
bon j'aime bien la mise en perspective
du jeu par rapport aux candidats et
comme on a fait aux est loin d'un vous
êtes dans cette ligne là je pense plus
dans la ligne courbe et que dans la
ligne kelly moi je préfère julien
courbet mais c'est vrai que arthur c'est
vrai qu'il était très bon aussi les deux
solides et moi je vous dise la vérité
qui juge le dis franchement je pense que
c'est l'émission arthur était le
meilleur about chaînette mois les boîtes
prochaine faisait bien avec la grotte
millions et pour moi pour moi c'est
l'émission ou arthur admis le menu les
boîtiers pas ce tampon serait non je te
jure je tends dans les autres émissions
je vois ici c'est bien mais là je trouve
que les boîtes et obéissants il après
après que je viens avait été moi je peux
vous donner mon avis parce que j'aime
tellement julien combes et forcément il
va être biaisé mon avis mais c'est vrai
que si je préfère julien parce que
j'aime julien mais arthur je dis
franchement là je suis honnête dans les
boîtes ils étaient très bons aussi alors
oui il en revient justement moi je les
maltraiter à dire la décontraction de
julien combes et parce qu'il a un côté
crooner la d1 c'est une sorte de dieu
martin et donc sa j'adore
dumas et dans mon souvenir arthur
n'était pas aussi bon que ça m'aide en
le voyant je me suis dit les bruins est
quand même sacrément bon là devant moi
j'ai vu qu'ils ont mis six ans
faire sortir le jeu pendant six ans le
créateur n'avez pas à le vendre il est
sorti je prends en turquie et après la
turquie les revenus en amérique
tellement de journée quand tf1 a pris le
jeu ils ont commandé gens sinon ça ne
marchera jamais un jeu une des boîtes
ont en effet des échanges ça marchera
jamais c'était un carton incroyable et
ça sera donc de retour lundi comme
jamais à 20h15 ouais c'était une belle
feinte croyez pas oui vous vous sentez à
quelques jours de l'animé êtes vous êtes
non je suis dans c'est que du kif et je
vais dire moi je prends les matches les
uns après les autres je serai dans à
prendre ou à laisser
lundi à 20h15 oui je le trouve julien
courbet très drôle et on aime beaucoup
ici mais stratosphérique mans c'est
arthur les boîtes pour moi c'est arthur
il a été très fort arthur qu'elle a fait
les boîtes de livres en pleine gueule
parce qu'on ne connaissait pas on a
appris ça dans le coin de la gueule
comme ça en 2004 on arrive avec un
banquier des sommes astronomiques oui ça
c'est un cure-dent où tu peux gagner
cent mille je bougeais pas jeter qu'on
aura jusqu'à 250 mille euros le prix
arthur a démarré fort dans ce jeu là et
de 150000 euros à gagner dès lundi
regardez tient le sondage du public et
ce qu'ils ont dit marc tu rases à laval
à 5,49 s'est passé assez serré voilà je
vous dis logis mais je voulais je vous
dise moi je suis comme les
téléspectateurs j'arriverai qui arrive
qu'on va choisir car elle va choisir
voilà les deux ces deux styles ont eu
très très différente bon style hélas ce
qui va être intéressant c'est moi je
savais comme j'ai la passion pour le
direct ce mal est intéressant c'est la
grecque parce que moi je sais ça que je
kiffe moi je dis que tu ris quand tu
regarde une émission
excusez moi de prendre 10 secondes quand
tu regarde une émission au kiosque où tu
sais qu'elle est enregistrée on la coupe
et on a refait ça se trouve il n'a pas
dit ça rassure et ça a été pilotée moi
je préfère la fina par exemple merci je
vous parle je vous fais chier mais on y
tue nos péchés